[Musique]
la vague de la criminalité de la
violence le rapport meise plat connaît
très bien on s'entretue pour couleurs de
flag vous serez surpris de la vague on
commence son père c'est jean raymond
claude un des membres fondateurs du gang
67 à la fin des années 90 dans le
quartier saint michel j'suis des fois ça
m'arrivait je veux demander à moi c'est
parmi les musées keystone agents de
sécurité et son pareil c'est ducarme
joseph un caïd du crime organisé
assassiné en 2014 steven l'extrême tout
comme trop gourmand à 14 ans il commence
à commettre des vols à l'étalagé son
père en prison à l'époque était fier de
son fils quand parler criminalité ben là
était une force pour moi c'est une façon
de me rapprocher de mon père je ne
voyais pas souvent enfin j'ai pas trouvé
d'autres moyens j'ai fait des affaires
bien pire bien pire que braquer des
dépanneurs par la suite aujourd'hui un
jour garde ce soir
en 2015 son univers bascule son père est
kidnappé présumément assassiné moi j'ai
deux enfants maintenant je sais que j'ai
fait le calcul de tout ça puis je me
suis dit c'est peut-être pas le chemin
approprié même si à des guides et des
sommes importantes d'argent si je
préfère faire moins mais au moins de
voir mes enfants grandir je pars
répétaient le même pattern que mon père
a fait avec moi jamais vous pour eux
maintenant ce n'est plus dans la rue que
l'artiste de 25 ans consacre son temps
mais entre le studio d'enregistrement
est chez lui avec sa famille moi y'a
plein plein de moments que je me sens je
me sens soit je me sens un peu perdue
puis je met un but puis je commence à
écrire que ce qui me passe par la tête
du coup je m'ai fait de son prix
circulent propos du buzzer après que
j'ai fini qu'à la chanson mais j'ai
oublié le mal est ce que j'avais je
savais le cas la chanson que je suis
fier déclina wakrim h en sort c'est la
vie que divers c'est tout simplement ça
je veux pas raconter une histoire qui
est pas la mienne
cette réalité connaisseurs tikazone la
connaît aussi très bien pour nous et
donc voir si de ma vie se sortait de
chez nous aujourd'hui mon couteau je
retournais rêve je me sens un peu non
pommier sava couteau à 44 ans le vétéran
rappeur affiliés un vieil criminaliser
d'allégeance rouge à l'époque revient
sur cinq premières chansons de son
nouvel album s'intitule la rue mattel
encore la revue rappelle encore gelé
tous jockey mof de piques l'une des
raisons pourquoi j'ai commencé c'est
justement que moi dans ce temps là quand
je cours sera plus ce serait vraiment
dit dans le sud c'est quoi ta définition
d'être dip dans le script et impliqués
dans la violence mais genk fusillade
couteau puis tu sais comme c'est que ces
constantes
il a perdu plusieurs de ses amis sous
les balles avec les années en 2007 il
est condamné à quatre ans de prison pour
vol à main armée ça oui j'ai toujours
été un gars que je préférais la facilité
genk j'ai jamais eu de pitié de moi je
n'ai jamais été de même j'étais pris la
main pour nous par les circonstances
devraient tomber coupé après une
altercation dans un bar en 2015 il
décide de faire une croix sur l'univers
de la rue sucre goodall aussi que cet
incident ne m'ont rien c'est très facile
[Musique]
mais que se passe-t-il dans les rues de
montréal pour miles up un meilleur
encadrement des jeunes à l'école serait
une solution on l'apprend pas la vie
mais écoutant de la vie ces jeunes là
ils sont dans la rue et font plein
d'argent qui savent même pas quoi faire
avec il s'agit des armes et puis il se
trouve cool avec qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire pour les jeunes si je pensais
ouvrir plus de maison des jeunes ont
donné des activités home était le sport
gratuit je sais pas
les jeunes ont rien à faire des
travailleurs de rue plus de gens dans
les quartiers des gens qui vont qui vont
aider ces jeunes là qui vont leur
montrer le chemin puis qu'ils vont pas
leur montrer une fois qu'ils sont qui
sont dans la merde qui sont déjà au
centre jeunesse puisque c'est là qu'il
va avoir un travailleur qui va essayer
de l'aider mais il ya déjà merdé ça sans
que rien de l'aider à 14 ans à 13 ans
leur montrer c'est quoi la vie sinon ils
vont la découvrir par eux-mêmes puis
vont se casser la gueule nous une
situation qu'on a vu neuf ça fait 17 ans
que roberson berlin travaillent avec les
jeunes de montréal nord qu'est ce que
l'on voit aujourd'hui
les problématiques qui surgissent ce
sont des choses qui sont latentes depuis
très longtemps les conflits sont reliés
puis à des gangs de rue mais la
problématique est beaucoup plus complexe
je pense que c'est réducteur que de le
mettre juste gare de guingamp zone 43
profonde lâchement c'est réducteur parce
qu'il ya à travers ces conflits là il ya
des histoires personnelles il ya des
histoires peut-être deux d'argent et
puis si on fait juste regard des guerres
de gangs ben on sacrifie des jeunes qui
sont sur la mauvaise place la solution
se trouve peut-être en changeant notre
approche vis-à-vis les jeunes criminels
en dehors delà de laquelle la personne a
commis qu'il ya une histoire qui l'a
amené à commettre sa cage slovaque on
est avec une arme dans la main on n'est
pas mauvais comme iliad et s'il ya des
histoires qui amène là puis je pense le
travail de rue particulièrement ses
dettes et revenir
à un moment donné dans la boue cette
personne-là plus de changer cette
histoire là car c'est par choix que j'ai
enfilé des grades pour connaisseurs
tikazone il faut arrêter de victimiser
les jeunes et les responsabiliser et des
endroits que c'est vraiment super pole
pour pas de job papa de bouffe pas le
choix devant du crack manger ici c'est
pas comme ça ici c'est surtout par choix
fait comment tu peux arrêter un gars qui
s'il fait soit par choix c'est ce qu'ils
font soit parce qu'ils n'avaient pas un
choix qui peut aider fait le gars de 19
ans qu'il a dit le conseiller j'ai peur
parce que dans les 10 mois au regard et
qu'on aurait pu attirer toi tu poses
commencé pour vise la crème vie des gens
son âge pour la musique a fait descendre
le combo coup parce que pleinement
décider qui est un criminel qui ont
décidé je vais faire ma musique bat exec
va encore plus loin il se sert de son
art pour dénoncer la violence et
envoyait un message d'unité
et justement dans l'une de ses dernières
chansons il collabore avec jack boy
affiliés au poids fit boys orateurs
associer un gang autre fois opposée à
lui plusieurs personnes ont salué
l'audace du geste il ya quelques années
le mois - l'union serait peut-être série
de ce point c'est parce qu'on venait de
tel coin tel coin mais quand nous on
pense à ça aujourd'hui on est comme on
en a fait du chemin merci dieu et ça
faisait pas de sens
du plaisir à nouveau à chicago
[Musique]